[Music]
welcome to the iron Lords podcast and we
are laughs I love podcast brought to
gaming dotnet this is Laura kognito news
this morning gentlemen we have in the
realm today I'm Gregory Everett from
Germany and I'm the PR guy from Hennepin
awesome awesome so we're here to discuss
this game dead age - all right so what
can you briefly tell us about that age -
yeah - it's a survival game and you will
fight in turn-based combat and but you
know not only I think that's a lot - but
you're not only fighting because it's
about regaining the community after the
zombie
don't be like a zombie apocalypse okay
good so it's it's happening after the
first part so there was that edge one of
course right after the events are part
one we're going right into parts yeah
okay that's great
hmm so yeah and it's it's about
recreating the the community so out of
nowhere and the the basement or the
basis were set with the first part and
now it's even even advancing sounds good
so we're gonna get right into this game
play man that Lord smiled Oh TV checking
it out dead age - gonna see what we
could see here we got a little story
beats going on right now
ten years ago zombification happening I
like that word zombie vacation several
factions emerged so we got some faction
gameplay going on as well alright few
human independence they failed the
undead returned it's on now and a horde
swept around all right let's get it
country roll you have you have to need a
good standing for example the
there's a US Army as one faction so if
you are bad with them you're standing as
bad you you won't get access to riches
for example and then you either can try
another way or you can try to fight them
but it's all relationships with faction
is very important in this game that
would affect gameplay yes and I'm
noticing like I said cool inventory
system going on right now looks like
know some songs try to get that knife
going that's a it looks like full
clothing each equipment spots you know
so look like you could truly outfit your
character that's the vibe I'm getting
yeah your whole team you know things
with one guy not with the whole team
later on right now it's it's the
beginning of the game gotcha
yeah actually just one day right after
the first fight alright so you can see
here it's turn-based so you can choose
what to
weapon and afterwards you can gather
some things for me also you can get a
bloody hand after you bloody hands are a
thing in this game
get your bloody hand shell casings cool
so we get loot drops from enemies that
we get okay able to trade in some stuff
you can't read it with defections
awesome right off the back I just want
to stop for a second you know the art
style looks fantastic very vibrant very
colorful now from what I'm seeing we're
a side-to-side moving game that's kinda
where okx want to get that clear yeah
right now it's it's like that but later
on is mayor about the okay so it will
have this the east types of segments but
like you said there's also base building
and that's a key component in the game
yeah awesome awesome this looks but now
I know so far with we were here the iron
rose we definitely like our turn-based
game so this definitely fits up the
alley as well as some it's a little bit
of Walking Dead a little zombie
apocalypse thing going on but a little
merge of genres that you did say at one
point that you can get other people in
your party or is it just one person no
it's a single player okay so good point
but you will have a team then of several
people in the in the game so also it's
still a so that you could switch yeah
right okay gotcha gotcha
that's what I wanted up here we go as a
whole team and we'll be strong cause in
reality if this would be a reality you
shouldn't go out there he did a team but
for fairness the sake of the game he has
a team at home he's running solo right
yeah cool cool so I did see some stuff
like you get that effect in fact there's
some deep defensive points involved so
it looks like everything that you equip
kind of has effects and status effects
and also the enemies yeah right awesome
also so meanwhile those story beat going
on yeah the story is told in some some
great pictures or artworks and many text
things mm-hmm so you can read everything
the first game was was very appreciated
by the community with the simplemente
and yeah we hope that the and so it
happened again with the second with the
second game fancy it looks really cool
but after me and I says unique style of
storytelling I mean I know a lot of
times
everything gets boombastic set up and
stuff like that but it looks like you
guys it's very narrative narratives
really driven through what you're
reading right now yeah right no gotcha
gotcha so yeah it's important to have
resources so so we're whole we have the
water and food yeah we got we got a
friend right now
so what helping us yes
you thing with us all right so I see
some options there now there's a
medicine option that he's picking you'll
see what's going on baby so P first of
all let me ask you a question like how
is it feeling it feels real nice for it
to be like a side-scrolling you type you
know story driven game it feels really
really good it feels like you have a lot
of options feels like you have a lot you
can do you can really pick your
characters also but what their abilities
are their skills are in the beginning
what they specialize in it's really
really good got the feel like in the
field right now I'm loving the engine
man it really beautifully graphed
graphically the game I just love the art
style I have to say that it's made by
one guy so it's really one German guy
Wow actually most of our games we were
showing this the specs are made by only
one that is super impressive do we know
possibly how long it's been in
development along he's been working out
or maybe how close we are to finish it
we don't know that whether the
the early access version will be soon
okay so we hope you look for early
access we did it with the first one and
it was a big success so he gets much of
feedback from the community and refines
everything and this is impressive for
early access yeah you could have told me
that you were getting close I believe so
this is no we don't know so hopefully we
don't break that beat it on right there
over there oh how would it play out
yes build up so again you say with the
success in the first game you listening
to the feedback from the community like
how involved with the community is all
right are you with this game like how
far is the community with you guys it
would the game I meant yeah right now
not not too much because it's not out
right but as soon as will be released in
the audience's the community will
hopefully snatch it yes with first one
that that worked out perfectly so of
course all the guys who were the first
one will be
notified nice so right now this is that
exclusive even the team that got the
fans of the first game not even aware
the greatness that's happening right now
that's great this happening right now
yeah this is awesome and it many guys
loved it so we hope that this will be
the time here it's everything is
advanced so you just just go out and
search for anything so for something but
you can choose where you want to want to
go and you you know that there's for
example water tower or something
and you know there's water to find and
then you can go exactly where you got
molotov you know miles or cartel what I
was fired I literally that was fired no
doubt this game looks really really cool
that there are two roles so you can
stand in the front row and use
and weapons okay just hit the guys in
the front or you can go back and you
have rails weapon no now that that is
depending on where you are is what
you're able to use your position yet run
interest is you can use ranged weapons
from the front side okay okay so you
don't get in there but but you're a bit
more secure for the attacks of the enemy
so awesome so now we got a little quest
started of radio from a scout job let's
say this is what a weird thing I'm gonna
say but I'm actually a fan of the UI I
even like the way to give a give credit
for a weird thing I actually like the
actually hit points even when you hit
the enemies when the way the display of
the statuses and the DHB actually looks
pretty aesthetically pleasing yes no
doubt so what's going on right now is
all first base here and there for
example you have a garden for sitting
some some plants you have the comm
center where you can check outs for more
supplies
yeah first of all I stated okay right
now be a state of decay vibes you can
create weapons there and emanation nice
but this will will come obviously yeah
now would you happen to know I know you
said you get more people right yeah like
will they stay in your basically is that
how it works you if you found them
yeah they will stay there so you will
just met some guys and they will gather
together and you know if they're good
and it comes from the from the Army for
example they they have young any dynamic
there between the other factions in that
regard so like you said I'll be as far
as like the other people use of the army
people never said any other on
interactions and everything and they're
traders of course you need something
some gangs oh we got gold
yeah ghouls are in this okay like so do
we happen to know anything about the
like it's just it's more of a
confrontational thing is it it depends
so sometimes they're friendly sometimes
they're not you always have to see like
it would be in reality perhaps
some crazy guys out there and some are
friendly so and then you have to check
out if you should fight them exactly
because I like that but I love that
unpredictability of it you know said you
have you don't know what you get a cup
across and again that's that climate of
a survival world you don't know what's
going on day two it made it to day two
so like I said so like I said I love
that aspect I'm gonna get survival
horror fun genre so we got a lot of
things going on a map right now looks
the game yeah go step by step
but you always have to check how much
water you get because you can't go too
far because otherwise right right so you
so basically is there any place where
you could monitor those vitals so that
you know like it's already where that
you are that's kind of showcases that
like hey I don't have enough water you
know yeah you I got you you can always
go back so I think you have seven hours
time to so you can go seven steps and
then your immunity will go back okay got
to go and a date or at daytime or at
night and I'm assuming there's a lot of
differences between both scenarios dice
that is really
very unique take as far especially as
far as the the viewpoint of the action
like I said very unique in that respect
oh so you only really it's quite safe
you know so bad so what else you got
going on PD what we see in it's like
we're we're gonna try to get some
supplies here so you know we got some
looks like we got some guys in the way
so we're gonna take those guys out looks
like and then we're gonna you know we're
gonna push through and then get those
supplies we need and get out
so anybody's been doing some charge up
bull-fucking-shit yeah so it looks like
there's you know the type of combat you
want against other you know type of
scenarios so you have courage to set up
the charge of the the these spitting
side for the buck Wow nice so yeah all
those things but um
looks like the combat has a front row
back row that allows you to move between
those two so that allows you to take
different defensive roles and and
offensive roles to bait against who
you're fighting which it's got that
really nice dynamic so if you have a
character that you know you want to have
more of a melee type or a tank type you
can have that in the front worse you can
have the others in the back it's good
man like I said I would like it to waste
looking the way it's code of again early
early access right now the fans don't
even know just yet but hopefully coming
soon to the public so that they will
know and then what can they do to
support it well we could do that what's
what you get to that point well just
and play it then of course get feedback
so it's it's very wealthy so yeah we
need to check out what's what's wrong
still or well are the box and stuff like
that so yeah that's that's perfect of
course check our Twitter page this game
plug it plug it man what's the Twitter
page put about yeah it's it's Twitter /
shut up game song okay you heard it here
first check it out you heard it here
first
I don't know podcast Lords of gaming
that they're dead age to head up games
the super exclusive super early look
right now it's four yards for the fence
actually you're one of the first guys oh
the Lord's are honored right there this
is an exclusive mom in an absolute
pleasure to have you it around me to
dead age to y'all I'll or podcast he was
gaming dotnet peace
you
[Music]